there are a lot of people that need
their abilities stretched to the limits
I feel like they should be able to do
more and there is something getting in
the way of them fulfilling their
potential I really need something to
pick me up cuz I'm tired so I bought a
bottle and it tasted like piss what the
hours and hours of phone calls designs
that we liked and designs that we hated
the five final fonts that we're picking
out in the middle of the flipping night
that first thing that we had was a
monstrosity there is no chance in hell
that anyone is trying any of those and
going wow yeah they'll go and what did
you say yeah it's quite nice I it's
quite nice it's not been easy we falling
out quite a bit didn't kill each other
somehow if it doesn't taste as good but
different if it's not as good it's this
is hard this is
[Music]
difficult so here we
are 12
months of messaging each each other late
at night and first thing in the morning
and we're still talking we're still
amicable that's impressive well done we
made it we made it we made this project
harder than it needed to be because we
wanted to be involved every single step
of the way we didn't step into an
existing product an existing project
where someone said here's a formulation
throw your names on the front of it we
were here from before day
one the problem that we're trying to fix
for customers is that they feel like
they're built for more they feel like
they should be able to do more and there
is something getting in the way of them
fulfilling their potential it's like
you're already enough but we need to
unlock that potential and you can unlock
that by using the drink power your
productivity is a lot more soft I think
than fuel your focus it doesn't have
anywhere near as much punch last night
by the way I was on the way to train at
6 PM so I went into a Servo and I was
like oh I really need something to pick
me up because I'm tired but I don't want
to have too much caffeine I can't sleep
so I bought a bottle instead of a bottle
of and I actually became our demographic
for that kind of even in uh pickup and
it tasted like piss it was the worst
tasting thing I've ever had it it
literally I was driving down the road
saying out loud what the and it filled
me with hope that as long as we bring
the message in the market together and
create something that tastes good we can
do very well for quite a while I'd been
thinking I would love to do a neutop
energy drink of some kind and I'd had it
in my head for ages and I moved out to
America and the wellness scene out there
is way more Progressive I started
talking to your manager my tour manager
Luke and
said I'd really love to do like some
sort of brain enhancing cognitive
performance drink and he said James is
working on one of those and I thought
but that was a long time ago if I'm
honest to me before the events before
the shows before anything the most
important thing for me was priming
myself and if I was a diva about
anything it was right I need to be ready
for what I'm about to do more
cognitively and more mentally than
anything else so my passion for energy
drinks neut Tropics as well for years
I've almost been self-medicated a desire
to be productive alert and
cognitively my best someone called you a
connoisseur almost yeah and literally
it's been a 10 year Journey without even
realizing from pre-workouts to
supplementation to all these different
things when we started the project I
already had a pretty good based
understanding I was like cool this is
what I've used this is what I recommend
this is what I done this was efficacious
this one wasn't the one thing that
really excited me about this was that
before when I had this concept in my
mind of having something that could help
people be more productive or Focus part
of me you know used pre-workouts to get
ready and the grittiness I didn't you
fall out of love with anything that you
mix with water for too long and then
supplementation taking pills again my
favorite way of getting myself ready for
training session whatever it is is
having like a nice beverage it's an
enjoyable experience right and you can
throw it in a bag you can do whatever
speaking of that can we open these now
CU I'm oh yeah thank
God cheers cheers
mate so why is it so important to you
that we were to create a productivity
drink over an energy drink the reason
that we made this product is for the
challenges that both of us face and we
know that we are not alone we did a
survey of more than 15,000 of our
combined audience members about what
they were struggling with most and
staying focused having energy that
doesn't crash and go through highs and
lows throughout the day not getting
distracted when they're trying to stay
on task like we made this for those
people like we took the research and we
ensured that this fixes the problem that
they have as far as I can see
um we've been keeping our eyes on this
market for a long time there's nothing
on the market that actually does what we
wanted it to do when I started modern
wisdom that was the podcast that I
wanted to listen to when I was younger
and nutonic is the drink that I wanted
to drink but wasn't available there are
a lot of people that are working on
tasks that need good focus and attention
there are people that need their ability
stretched to the limits and it's them
now to know that there's more than a cup
of coffee from the coffee machine that
they can lean on I feel is liberating so
the fact that people can you know
legitimately as it says in the tagline
feel their focus better is an exciting
thing to me well we made it yeah exactly
like actually like hours and hours and
hours of phone calls and voice notes and
photos backwards and forwards and
designs that we liked and designs that
we hated and color palettes and studies
and all sorts of stuff so much of that
went back and forth I feel so much more
connected to this because I know every
single thing that's on the back of the
can I know all of the different pan
turns that we went through like hundreds
and hundreds of different color
combinations how wide is the eye going
to be whether or not we would to have
five things on this side we were going
to have three is it research Dash backed
neut Tropic ingredients or is it
research backed neut Tropic ingredients
the five final fonts that we had for the
title that we're picking out in the
middle of the flipping night you may now
be able to see why it's taken 12 months
for us to get this across the line but I
feel I feel genuinely connected to this
which is nice and even if you were to
rewind over a year I've been trying to
sell people into this before we even
created it so I've been people okay you
got to get the right amount of caffeine
but that's not just the only thing you
need what you need is other compounds
that can help you concentrate for longer
periods of time and then when I was
recommending people they're like okay so
I need caffeine I need this I need this
and then they look like they would Shake
if they would to take everything they
needed so the fact that I can take that
same passion that I have towards
productivity and then put it in in line
of our project just yeah gets I'm
excited so then obviously we discussed
about some sort of illustration and I
think my just slightly tweaked this but
see if you guys like it um obviously we'
gone hard on the eye but if you if you
were to think of the eye could be a bit
more relaxed but in terms of as a design
it looks pretty cool that's pretty
cool I think the wow both of those are
really interest I love the two-tone what
do you think James I really like the
two-tone as well the eyes look a little
bit
stoned you know like doesn't scream Al
to me I I have to say I'm really really
big fan of that eye um which I like if
you'd said we're going to put a huge
pair of eyes on it I would not have
guessed if we were to say right guys
blindly you've got to uh you got to
without looking get a pen and paper and
design the can of what looks like what
looks like uh what looks like people
would actually probably have a quite a
phazzy foggy idea of what the can look
like and now so many of these new cans
come to market look the same someone
only needs to see us mention this once
to never forget what it looks like like
a police lineup you know like you're not
going to foggy the water someone puts a
gun to your head what did the can look
like oh was it was it two ton did it say
this I like the fact that we use the eye
to catch people's attention which is the
one thing we're all fighting for to
maintain our attention so there's a bit
of a story with that as well where like
this it's so I look it's yeah it's just
cool we did probably closer to four
months of taste testing remotely I mean
that first thing that we had was a
monstrosity I wouldn't I would abs
absolutely not go to market with that
there is no way there is no way that we
could take that to Market we can just
like cast that one off I think that's
still not right to me for four I like
four four's the leader Four's overtaken
too I would say that Four's four's the
best but there's
still still not there let's say that I
bring hberman on the show or you you sit
down with like [__] Bartlett or
whatever and you like toss a can across
to him there is no chance in hell that
anyone is trying any of those and going
wow yeah they'll go I don't mean to be
like I understand that I'm being Captain
negativo over here I just think we have
to nail the taste like it's so important
that we nail this that first ever
version that we tasted and what did you
say yeah it's quite nice do you know
what I think it's quite nice I used to
work in a pub back in the day there was
you know lime soda it was a basic drink
it kept me busy maybe I was tasting
Nostalgia of a cheap hor and soda so C
yeah with soda water so I'm thinking it
was things that don't really have any
taste to them I think it was a nostalgic
taste I was getting maybe it was taking
me back to you know young James when he
was 18 19 whatever you
say the video can be I'm never working
you I'm in the UK doing the final taste
testing for our very own productivity
drink but we have had some troubles
getting the taste right I'm here for 40
hours going to go and live in the
factory tomorrow for an entire day do a
ton of sampling a ton of of testing and
by the time that we are finished we're
going to have a drink that is going to
knock your testicles off we've got
research backed evidence-based
ingredient profile the right levels of
everything everything is right except
for the fact that we haven't got the
flavor right if we don't get the flavor
right on this batch to like tomorrow we
miss the production run we miss summer
and we give everybody else that is
launching this stuff even more of a head
start than we already have cuz I haven't
been able to decide on stuff for 6
months and I'll have to go back to
selling PDF training
program to keep the electricity on this
this winter oh so this one so I'm going
I actually want to do that one
left five times a small so I again I
don't disagree the only thing is if it
doesn't taste as good but different if
it's not as good point we all
agree no I would say if you if you love
it then it's you we don't have to have
another round
Che gentlemen expecting to try
yeah quite heavy that is a heavy that is
a heavy
flavor going get more more caffeinated
these
arguments I like the carbonation as
well I actually don't like that that's
the last
one
impossible this is hard this is
difficult that's so there's like there's
things you legally have to put on
tast that it's not bad that's
money oh thank God best thing I've
tasted all
day isn't it Chris you got say it's
pretty nice 15 hours later we have come
up with several flavor profiles it's not
been easy we fallen out quite a bit
didn't kill each other somehow but I'm
excited because in all honesty we
brought the most popular flavors and we
put ours next to theirs and by the end
of it I can't believe people are selling
those disgusting flavors wipe the floor
with them wipes the floor with all of
them took so long to get this base right
and now we have a signature flavor
profile which is nicer than everything
that everybody's selling it's
[Music]
wild
formulation
was actually relatively simple in terms
of what we were going to put in the team
came back with a pretty obvious
hierarchy of what was the most
evidence-based what had the most
reliable uh human-based trials in
healthy adults and it's what we put in
here the expensive part was that we all
wanted to make sure it was in
efficacious doses so we didn't just want
to say there's a proprietary blend
there's a little sprinkling of a few
different things so that we can claim
that it's got these different things in
it we actually wanted to make sure that
it was a dosage to actually be effective
and as part as the story was going for
this so when we first looked at the
ingredients that we were going to put
into the drink I actually then went to
other people that had no idea I was
working on a project and I actually said
to them I was doing a hit piece and I
said there's this supplement mix of
ingredients out there I think it's
rubbish can you help me do a hit piece
so I sent it off to someone in the
evidence-based community and he came
back and he pretty much said like you're
going to really struggle because these
ingredients are legit and then I told
him I said actually thank God for that
thank God for
that and imagine if he'd said yeah mate
all rubbish get it yeah take it down so
that was a very you know great part in
the beginning to make sure that we were
on the right tracks and we w living in
an echo chamber of you know deciding
what was in it but yeah I'm really happy
with with the ingredients and how they
make me feel I guess one of the
questions especially given what you've
been talking about on YouTube recently
that a lot of the audience will be
thinking is what's in it why did you
choose the things that are in it so why
don't we spend a little bit of time
explaining
that one important thing to note is that
we are not citing studies and trials
that's primary subject is rats old
people or those with Parkinson's are
outside this one of the key ingredients
that we included is cognizin cognizin is
a heavily studied cyto Coline that
impacts Focus attention and memory a
study from 2015 found that adolescent
males receiving cognizin every day for
28 days showed improved attention
compared to adolescent males who
received a placebo for the same period
similarly a study on 60 healthy adult
women aged between 40 and 60 showed that
when supplementing 500 Mig of cognizin
they made significantly fewer commission
errors compared to those in the placebo
group this shows a increase in attention
this is why we put 500 Mig a full half
gram of cognizin into this drink so a
couple years ago I was taking a
anti-cholinergic that was just like
prescribed by the doctor it was
something that I needed to take no big
deal but I started taking it and then
one day I was at the beach and I forgot
the name of the small Seaside town next
to Manchester Blackpool and for 3
minutes I couldn't remember Blackpool
and what had happened was they doubled
my dose of this anticholinergic about a
week and a half before I didn't realize
that Coline is a key
neurotransmitter cognizin is a branded
cytool so it's doing the opposite of
what happened when I took that antolin
urgent largely both of us are cognitive
athletes right that's how I see my job
and I'm really really in tune with the
text of my mind so if something's off I
know straight away if I haven't slept
enough if I'm not hydrated if I've eaten
too much sugar and then I take this
anti-al energic thing and it's just
like 30% of my Ram has just been ripped
out from underneath me and my thoughts
are muddy it was awful so yeah I think
having such a massive dose the maximum
legal dose that we can get of cognizant
in this I was so confident even just
coming in having had that one experience
that was really uncomfortable to be
honest like I really hated it I'm like
oh maybe this is me for the rest you
know like the same sensation you have if
you ever smoke too much weed you're like
I'm going to be stuck like this forever
I thought I'm never going to be able to
remember black cool again and um yeah so
cogniz in very very important to me the
other ingredient we included was Rola
Rosa which is a powerful adaptogen
adaptogens are plant extracts that
impact the way your body responds to
stress and fatigue a study on nurses
working in high stress environments
collected data in categories such as
mental fatigue concentration over time
and short-term memory it found that
there was a statistically significant
Improvement in all three tests meaning
that in these cases R Rosa had helped
with relieving stress induced by fatigue
so if it helps these Healthcare
professionals working in life and death
scenarios it can help you do your emails
Rod Ros is an interesting one because
I've been a human guinea pig trying a
lot of these things for quite a while
I've been mentioning in videos for 6 to
12 months and this one I remember I was
supplementing at the time I do in a
pretty stressful business talk in the
Gold Coast and I noticeably felt better
as time went throughout the day usually
as we get to about 2 3 p p.m. I start
crashing a bit fly through feeling
better wondering if whether or not I was
just getting better at talking turns out
I wasn't the you might have been getting
better at talking as well no probably
not probably not so uh yeah I've got
firstand experience of that one where
after that event and supplemented that
became a non-negotiable for me moving
forward another ingredient we included
is panex ginang the primary active
compounds in panic jinsang are Gino sdes
these Gino sdes Aid the body in
adjusting to a range of mental and
physical challenges while fostering a
sense of equilibrium and well-being
these are Jin sang for cognitive
augmentation has a long history rooted
in traditional medicine particularly in
East Asian cultures a double blind
Placebo controlled study comparing 30
healthy adults supplementing panex
Jensen against a placebo control group
found that panex Jens can improve
cognitive performance and feelings of
mental fatigue during sustained mental
activity this sustained focus is exactly
what lots of people struggle with as
your day continues you notice that your
ability to focus degrades over time you
continue to pump more caffeine into
yourself hoping that it's going to help
you control whatever it is you've got in
front of you so this is why panx jinang
is a big Advantage first day that came
up ordered some online I was like look
I'm going to try this out see what it's
like and yeah over time that was one
that I've then became quite proud of
having it as an ingredient in the drink
the Jin sang reduction in being
distracted by different tasks I think
for me as well was was pretty important
because if I'm trying to research a
guest if I'm trying to stay focused
whilst having a conversation with
somebody that's the most important thing
like the energy is great but not getting
distracted not moving onto other tasks
all of that combined together so I did
this event in La probably about a month
and a half two months ago that week I
did Eight Episodes in three states in
seven days and then I did six episodes
between Vegas and LA in four days two a
day for two of the days and one a day
for the two on either side and there's
no way that I would have been able to
get through it had I not have been using
them one of the ingredients that we
decided to include was caffeine
caffeinated beverages have been consumed
by people for centuries one problem with
being overly reliant on caffeine is it's
not fantastic for your sleep and and if
you start to use it too much the next
day you're going to need more caffeine
to achieve the same effect only having
one lever to press which is the caffeine
lever is not good which is why we knew
that caffeine on its own wasn't enough
this is why we added Aline Aline is a
natural amino acid that is mainly found
in tea leads alanine is thought to
enhance Alpha Brain Wave activity the
relaxed but alert mental state
associated with alpha waves can promote
creativity focus and attention during a
randomized in control trial on the
combination of alanine and caffeine the
data showed an improvement in both speed
and accuracy of performance of an
attention switching tasks and reduce
susceptibility to distracting
information in the memory task the use
cases for this are obvious and plain I
think the average amount of time that
any knowledge worker spends on a single
task is under 60 seconds now it's like
40 seconds and task switching is
unbelievably destructive to your
productivity Aline and caffeine are the
perfect partners with caffeine you get
the alertness and the reduction in
sleepiness and with Aline you get the
relaxed mental state so you're able to
be focused and the task in hand and
you're also going to be sufficiently
relaxed that you can actually perform
and feel good about it so big one for me
what I knew that we had to have in from
before we even started working together
I knew that there had to be Athenian in
because after 500 days without caffeine
my caffeine tolerance is so sensitive
that I need aling to smooth that out so
you kind of have this it's almost like a
little bit of a sea Sal right you get
agitated by the caffeine which is good
because it makes you less sleepy and it
makes you more alert but what it also
does is it can make you feel a little
bit kind of uptight and it can sometimes
make your brain feel a little bit
scattered and the Aline for me I'd been
taking tablets of Aline just with
coffees because that was the only way
that I could really have a coffee when I
came back after having a break from
caffeine so yeah I um I knew that we had
to have Alin in which has ended up
making the whole experience less like a
rush less like getting punched in the
face and more like accelerating really
nicely in a fast car I think you did ask
people what's the number one
productivity drink on the planet and
they go uh coffee well that's not a
productivity drink is it it's not being
designed for productivity it happens to
be a useful drink that has some
productivity enhancing effects that come
along for the ride but this is purpose
built from the ground up the dose of
caffeine not overshooting over 120
milligram which I had to fight with you
to get it down from because
you can be a bit of a caffeine fiend and
I'm like a caffeine wimp after taking
such a big break and I think that 120
milligrams is bang on the dose that we
want especially with the Aline to kind
of smooth it out bang on the dose you
can sit down it tastes so nice that
you're going to Chin it if it's cold and
if you're thirsty and if you down 200
300 milligrams of caffeine in 5 minutes
guess what like you're vibrating your
way through a near anxiety attack for
the next half hour or two hours so it's
the right amount for me it makes me feel
fantastic this is my favorite
flavor this is mine this I'm such a
sucker for orange man anything orange
I'm always a big a big fan of one other
thing that I guess it's not a a claim
that we've made anywhere on the product
but the difference it makes to my mood I
associate this taste with being more
focused with being more productive so
there's this weird vicious feedback loop
of me liking the taste of it and liking
the effect of it which means that when I
taste it next I get for the effect to
happen and it's kind of this spiral now
and also over time this isn't just
something that you take now in fact this
is like a really important point that we
made from the very beginning it couldn't
be a drink it couldn't be a product that
borrows from tomorrow to pay today it
had to be something that would make you
perform better today and then if you
took it tomorrow make you perform even
better tomorrow and then after that and
so on and so on it Bridges the Gap
really nicely between performance
enhancer and supplement and I think that
that blend between the two is it's it's
rare to find every time that I drink
most energy drinks it feels like I am
cashing out of tomorrow's energy to be
able to fuel
today you know that really famous meme
photo of H Simpson like throttling
B and we're fighting each other a little
bit it's going well it's going well um
what we've
got I'm happy James is also about 3 Mig
of caffeine deep so that may explain why
he feels the way he does the name oh my
God you were ready to take the first
name that we came up with and I must
have caused another subsequent 10
meetings you wanted to call it
bum yeah have a bump have a bump slap
wasn't slap one of them cheat cheat that
was it you want go cheat are you
cheating on
me yeah relatively harmonious I think
working relationship especially given
how how awkward I've been so we're going
to sit down in this Factory tomorrow
right and taste all of these different
drinks flavors that we've got pretty
close on James said yes to the first
one everybody else was like this is
awful we can't we can't go ahead with
this James was ready to ship it James
was ready to put a Canon bump that
tasted like the top filtering of a
septic tank and ship it it would have
been it would have been on sale
already
twist
one still got it still got it Ser never
had
it doesn't even know what it is you're
enjoying this don't want to be in Austin
right now shouting at you my name is
Chris and I talk to famous people and
because of that I had to spend the day
of James Smith today and every so often
I give back to the community giving back
to the community means bringing someone
along who is disadvantaged in many ways
I don't care what everyone said about
your podcast in the first year I lik
what do you think would have
happened to the process of creating this
had it not been for me would have been
done a lot sooner to but to be honest
okay maybe I will concede on the fact
that my my taste buds may be a little
bit basic but then if I was to flip the
question over to you Chris how do you
think the process would have been if you
were left to do the project on your oh
God we would have not been anywhere near
Market I would have still been in the
name the name planning stage Luke would
have killed me the guys that were
producing it they would have killed me
as well another thing that we did is
launch in America and the UK on Amazon
with prime next day delivery from launch
I suppose what we wanted was a massive
part of our audience to be able to try
what we've created and I mean as far as
an investment for this to happen as well
right this is the biggest it's the most
amount of money that I've ever put into
anything ever and plus you plus all of
the guys behind the scenes as well it's
it's a terrifying amount of money I
think it's a really important product I
think that right now this move toward
holistic productivity right it's it's a
a
ecological well balanced approach to
productivity it's not sort of nose for
the grindstone completely destroy
yourself it's I went to work really
really hard at the things that I do I
want to feel satisfied at the end of the
day and then I want to go and do
something else maybe before you do
Brazilian jiu-jitsu because something
else that you haven't said it's only
lightly carbonated so we wanted to make
sure that it wasn't such heavy
carbonation that it destroys the taste
the taste so good and super high
carbonation actually ruins how something
tastes so we dialed that back so it
doesn't give you any like digestive
discomfort especially if you drink it
quickly I suppose what we want is for
not just to crank people so they put
more effort into something but they
become more effective of what they're
doing so yeah for for us to be able to
get it everywhere so that people can
have the ability to have it for all
these things are are conversations we've
been having for so long to make sure
that it is legitimately the right thing
for that like you say could be going to
Jiu-Jitsu could be studying at home
could be you know needing a little
pickme up in the afternoon where you're
having a post pral LOL in the office or
whatever it is yeah I guess you know if
any of the things that we've spoken
about today resonate with people then
they can go and try it's available on
Amazon it's got next day delivery on
Amazon Prime you go to newtonic
docomo about today is detailed at
neic.org
actually help you unless you buy
it so head to Amazon get yourself a case
and don't just take our word for it we
sat oh it's amazing it tastes amazing
you get to find out for yourself buy it
put it in the fridge be more productive
enjoy
you